[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my black
lightning episode 2 video fantastic
episode my man we got our version of a
Netflix Luke Cage style hallway fight
and we got to see a Nissa use her powers
in a more conscious way even though it
was still reflexive she was just
responding in the moment I think the
next episode is when we'll start to see
her be more active about it I love the
way she reacts to it like she's just
rolling with it like yeah that's pretty
cool all right back to bed back to my
girlfriend so I will say just because I
forgot to say at the beginning of the
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet there were a couple
more big comic book Easter eggs mostly
having to do with thunders character
lightning still hasn't manifested her
powers yet but she's on this downward
spiral like drinking in the middle of
school when your dad is the principal
very clearly she's gonna get herself
into a situation where she'll have a
freakout moment like Thunder does and
her powers will manifest too but they'll
be a little bit different she's a track
star like you can see her eyes light up
in the first trailer that they drop so
you know it's gonna happen pretty soon
but we have to say the music is
fantastic in this series maybe they're
able to spend more on the music budget
because it's only 13 episodes instead of
being 17 18 23 like the other DC TV
series but whatever they did like the
actors that they chose going with older
actors that were a little more
experienced I think was a really good
call because all the performances were
fantastic I think it all just goes back
to the idea then trying to do a more
mature story and why they want to
insulate it from a lot of the other
stuff that's going on on the other TV
shows like a lot of people have been
pointing to the way that they get their
powers like they're born with them they
passed them on biologically like the
daughters are not going to get powers
there are probably other people that
will pop up you know the other shows
most people get their powers from Dark
Matter explosions Speed Force lightning
or just random accidents but a lot of
people have pointed out the funny fact
that even though they changed the
setting of the city to Freedland
originally black lightning was from
suicide slum a slum of metropolis in
just right away you notice the
contradiction why would Superman allow a
slum to exist in a place that he called
his hometown so it's almost like there
was a place in Metropolis that Superman
never visited so it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense so naturally it makes sense
the Superman the Supergirl wouldn't pop
up every single week because sort of
getting into the meat of the plot you
have Black Lightning finally
going after Lala and they do a really
good job of being very clear with their
progression like you know video game
your work your way up to the final boss
you know mid boss is done now it'll be
interesting to see which other mid Bad's
pop up before he has a confrontation
with Tobias well because he's the big
boss obviously the big final fight isn't
gonna happen till the finale which is
still at least 11 episodes away but
there are a lot of gangs in town so I
have a feeling you know you cut the head
off of a Hydra three heads grow back in
his place so they're just gonna be other
gang members that will rise up from the
comics that he'll take down on his way
to take him down to buy as well but by
the time we get it to buy us well I
think that we'll have a nice in a comic
book costume in possibly lightning - but
it just remains to be seen what they're
gonna do with the Lightning character
because right now she does feel very
juvenile in all the actors performances
I feel like hers was the weakest but all
of her scenes that she has with Black
Lightning and her sister are all great
so if you're not as big a fan of some of
this kind of stuff I have a feeling that
you get two more superhero family by the
end of the season
it a lot of people have secretly thought
that this is going to be a Batman Beyond
show eventually not right away but
eventually they'll get to the point
where Jefferson Pierce like you can see
him racked in pain is it looks like the
Lightning is eating his body alive
eventually gets so torn up that he does
have to take a more support role and his
daughters who are just coming up take a
more active role so anytime you see him
writhing on pain in the bathroom floor
shoveling painkillers into his mouth
just remember that one of his
superpowers is not regeneration
eventually his body will give out but we
can talk a little bit more about how the
show is using his powers as we continue
to see because I'm expecting some minor
changes from the comics but speaking of
powers the daughter is pretty much
confirmed to be a female version of Luke
Cage now we'll see if she has any other
powers because we saw her hand coursing
with what looked like energy you can
call it red lightning it's just a little
bit different from Jefferson Pierce's
lightning but like I said in my episode
1 video she basically controls her
molecular density so she can make
herself super dense which gives her a
measure of super strength so I don't
know if they're gonna take it in a Luke
Cage direction because you can hurt Luke
Cage it's just that you have to RAM the
gun down his mouth it's only his skin
that's indestructible the next couple of
episodes
probably clarify that if she has the
same weaknesses as Luke Cage but it's
not like Superman's super strength where
he's essentially like a solar battery so
the more Sun he soaks up the stronger he
gets there will be a limit to her
strength and that just sort of backs up
the idea that there are consequences to
what the heroes are doing on the show
like that's why you see black lightning
writhing in pain because they want to
make it seem real
like imagine Supergirl she got her face
bloodied up but there was no visible
blood in just in the second episode you
saw a bunch of people get killed at
close range with handguns so it's just
way more hardcore than the other TV
shows and I think people are enjoying
that just a little more realistic
serious take on the material but I do
like the idea that he could be addicted
to his powers now I think that both his
wife and Peter gambie are wrong like
there is an element of thrilled that you
might be addicted to but I don't think
he's literally addicted to his powers
but I do think you know they talk about
addiction on this TV show addiction will
eventually kill you
his love for what he does will
eventually kill him but I love Peter cam
B's line we're all gonna die someday
like if you're gonna die someday you
might as well doing it something
worthwhile so you can't be too mad at
his wife but the way they left it at the
end of the episode tells you what's
going to happen like she's like I'm not
having any of this if you're gonna
continue to be black lightning so that's
why she walks out the door he sort of
accepts it but here's the thing if the
daughters get powers and he has powers
and the mom knows about it then does
that mean that they can all be special
together because him having powers is
what she treated like a curse it drove
him away from their family but if almost
everybody in the family has powers
wouldn't that bring them back together
so I have a feeling you'll see that
plaid over the course of the season so I
do think that eventually if the wife is
alive at the end of the season which I
think that she will be she and Jefferson
will get back together of a fashion but
they'll probably just start doing it
again and speaking of doing it so Anissa
confirmed has a girlfriend now and they
made a joke about it like what's that
girl's name I can't remember
Chenoa so she's totally fine but in the
comics anissa's girlfriend is actually
grace choi who's an amazon from a like a
splinter tribe from the famous skier in
Amazonians
who is also a character on the show
so grace joy is the character on black
lightning but she looks much older so I
don't think they're gonna do the comic
book relationship or if they are it's
gonna happen way way down the road but
remember the way the flash TV show
treated the Wally West Linda Park
relationship in the comics like they
didn't even bother to go there in fact
Linda part dated Barry for a little
while but we'll see it's only episode
two so it's a little too soon to tell
exactly how they're gonna do all the
comic book characters but for the most
part I think it's wide open the other
thing they teased was a little bit of
Peter Gambas history so like he's not
just a tailor I talked a little bit
about it during my episode 1 video but
James remar the actor said that we would
get an episode explaining why it was
that he was helping Jefferson out so
much why he became as Alfred so
everybody just let me know what you
think of the episode so far and any
Easter eggs you spotted that I didn't
mention and let me know what you think
of Tobias whales character I have a
feeling that his connected nature in the
community will become a little more
complicated like you'll learn that he's
connected to some of the more legit
seeming people people inside the school
like you have miss Foudy here who seems
like she's trying to get up on jefferson
like she wants a piece of that so just
don't be surprised if this organization
the 100 that has been around for so long
and been so powerful does not have its
tendrils in other aspects of the
community but probably the best tip-off
for that is the Tobias whale was just
able to waltz into the police station
kill Lala and then walk out without
anybody looking at him twice like you
didn't see the police captain anywhere
so it sounds like he has some sort of
implied relationship with him so the
plot thickens remember it's only episode
two so real big news though is that we
might get some new infinity war footage
tonight there's a new flash video that
I'll probably do Friday explaining who
that mystery person is writing the
speedforce symbols and just peace all
that information together in a really
linear way but otherwise a whole bunch
of comic book stuff dropping really soon
we also found out we're getting a new
Deadpool 2 trailer pretty soon -
congratulations - the latest giveaway
winner des des parks please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll announce a new winner when
I post new DC so no worries click here
for brand new flash and click here for
my Easter eggs from episode 11 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight